so instead of doing a weekly challenge
I'm doing a motivation Monday for you
and I'm gonna give you two things here
one logically and imma sell it to
motional II why I believe every one of
you watching this knows how to get
success you don't need any more
motivational videos to tell you how to
get success but I'll break you down for
you so right now I'm in Santa Monica
doing the stairs which kicked my ass and
last night we brought crustaceans having
dinner with my family my sister and this
conversation came up afterwards and it
was very simple the conversation is that
one of the scariest moments in my life
was the day I realized I'm Tony it's
very scary that day I realize I can have
exactly the life that I want to have
this doesn't mean you can go become
whoever you want to be not at all I
didn't think I can go be LeBron James I
don't jump 44 inches and I'm not six a
280 I can't sell you can go become
anybody one you can go be Michael Phelps
no you can't these are very obvious
things to know not everybody can be
Michael Phelps right I can't go today
decide to become Michael Phelps I can't
go today decided to become the next Ted
Williams I can't
certain things you cannot do and that's
okay not everybody can go out there and
do a lot of things other people are
doing however however logically and
emotionally let me explain it to you
last night we're having dinner okay and
if you have crustaceans the armed family
this place in Beverly Hills it's just an
incredible restaurant and I'm speaking
of my sister and I said let me ask you a
question
she said yeah everybody's like well yes
I said out of what we ate tonight what
did we know that we shouldn't have eaten
if we didn't want to put on more weight
or carry on more additional car starts
whatever maybe right and everybody said
well noodles said what else well the the
the the dessert we just said okay what
else and so we went through it right oh
you know the
the crabs that we had that the lobster W
had Lila oil in it okay great
why do we eat it because we chose to eat
it why do we eat it cuz it's good okay
but we ate it yeah but we know it's not
good right yes but we ate it yes so
that's a scary thing let me explain to
you why we know if we ate it we have to
2x2 cardio the next day and if we don't
eat it we don't have to to X the cardio
the next day because if we to X the car
to you the next day we're getting closer
to getting shredded right or looking
better or cutting some bringing out more
the muscle be more defined be more
vascular but we a do we chose to eat it
okay the same goes that no one needs to
teach you and I that if you drink a lot
the night before an important sale in
the morning so you go out there
Wednesday night after everything is done
you go ham get hammered you party till
one o'clock in the morning you know you
got an 8 o'clock appointment a morning
to close if I don't drink and I prepare
10 times more than you do and you drink
you get hammered you party you stay up
and you come the next day lethargic I'm
gonna close the deal
over you are over you you know that I
know that so what happens there here's a
scary part every one of the decisions
you make you know stain on newsfeed
Facebook isn't good for you because you
can read a book instead of that you know
it you know yourself going party in
three four times a week is not good you
know nobody needs to tell you that you
know it you know exercising is good for
you you know it no one needs to make
five more million videos to tell you
that you need to go out there and you
know what to do you know it so logically
you know what to do you know what not to
eat you know exercise is good for you
you know communication works you know
reading books works you know all this
stuff why you choose not to do it is the
other part so let me give you the
emotional side of it the emotional side
of it is were such great sales people
because we convinced ourselves we have a
lot of time left we convinced ourselves
that I can do it tomorrow man I'm only
I can do tomorrow only 39 I mean I got
half my life to live young I mean my
twenties I should party I'm only nine
Tests you go out there and just hang out
who cares about being the discipline I
can't learn discipline of my 40s right I
don't need to take your my body I'm 25
I'm hot I'm a girl I'm drop-dead
gorgeous I don't need to work out I'm
hot at 35 when it goes it goes so you
emotionally sell yourself on not having
to do the work so now you watching this
there's two different kinds of people
one person like I was hoping to get
motivated oh my gosh I wanna I want you
to motivate no no the second person is
watching this says this I control the
kind of a life I can build and live why
am I not making the right choices to be
able to build a life for myself I don't
know only you can answer that not me not
anybody else only you I had to choose
others had to choose what are you going
to choose now here's another part of the
scary part you're gonna be seven years
old overnight I promise you go by so
quick who are we gonna be 55 years old
overnight I look around you look at your
parents did you think your parents were
gonna be that age did you didn't you
think your parents were gonna be around
for a long time some of you guys don't
have your mom and dad here with you I'm
here in LA right now for one reason my
dad's brother passed away I'm at a
funeral that's 66 years old he passed
away no one expected this man to pass
away in Iran he passed away that's why
I'm in LA life goes by quickly the
sooner you and I choose to make the
decisions that we know are right for you
and I that you have control over because
the sooner we start getting the kind of
results that get us to the dream life
that we want to live the only challenge
is you have to make the right choices
and no one else can do that for you not
the government not your parents not your
ex not your mom now your dad now your
brother not your sister not your
principal not your coworker you bought
nobody only you are in charge of that
that's both good news and bad news
because if you do right you're gonna get
what you want but if you blame it on
other people Oh
life is gonna be very hard my challenge
to use to make the right decision
because the life once you start making
it and start living the life you want to
live I wish there was a way to take your
life and put it in your five ten year
version from now body the life that you
can live and experience that to know how
incredible feeling that is for you to
say I want to get to today I wish that
there was a possibility of doing that
some kind of virtual reality if you say
no one day I want to wake up and by the
way that's another great idea I want to
have this ass on out of this karma and
for one day you live in there you say
man I want our life and you go work hard
to get it that's my message of the week
for you you got any thoughts on this you
willing to commit to doing this send me
a tweet at Patrick bit David love you
guys take care bye